[音楽]
ブードゥー君
今日は東京大学の鳴海託児と申します
私はバーチャルリアリティーの研究をしていますバーチャルリアリティっていうとです
ね
まあこういうイメージかなと思いますこういうヘッドマウントディスプレイとバル頭に
付ける様なディスプレイを装着して全然
この現実とは違う世界に行って何か楽しんで帰ってくると
まえーエンターテインメントとかそういうイメージがありますよね
で実際にですねこういう家庭用のゲーム機で使えるヘッドマウントディスプレイが
売り出されたり
1000円で買えるはダンボールのヘッドマウントディスプレイが売り出されたりとか
かなりそろそろ普及してきているのかなと思っています
2016年ぐらいにはバーチャルリアリティーがんで見たようなことが結構ニュース
なんかでも話題
だったと思いますこの中でバーチャルリアリティ
聞いたことある方というぐらいいらっしゃいますか
ほとんども皆さんなじみのものになってきていると思います
こんなになじんでたらもう研究者って何もやることないんじゃないの
たまに意地悪なことを言われます
でじゃあ僕らが何をやっているかというところからちょっと話していきたいんですが僕
らは vr を通じて自分の内面を知ってさらにそれを変えていくというような研究を
しています
その前にですねその基盤的な技術としてどうやって今のバーチャルリアリティの限界を
突破することができるかということを考えています例えばゲームをプレイするときこう
いうふうに座ってプレーして自分の体で動きもあることができませんでこの限界を突破
したいときにどういうことできるかってことを一つ紹介したいと思います
ん
なぜ歩けないかというとですね例えば歩いた時に人の体を追いかける装置があれば
バーチャルリアリティの中で動けるんですけれど実際にそれをやろうとすると
体験したい空間と同じ大きさの部屋が必要になってきます
もし皆さんのご家庭ですごく広い町
例えば神戸の街を vr で再現しましたというのを歩いて体験できるようにしようと
しても
おそらくみなさんの家庭だと壁にぶつかってしまいます
もしかしたら皆さん大富豪かもしれないのでとても広いお家をお持ちかもしれないです
が
まあ一般家庭ではやっぱり3m だけ3m ぐらいしか動けなくてそれ以上行こうと
すると壁に当たってしまう
そこで考えたのがこういうシステムです
図にあるように壁が曲がっています
でもヘッドマン2スプレーをかけた人にはまっすぐな壁紙へ
でこの壁を触ろうとすると実際に回った壁があるので触れることができるわけです
そうするとあれここにまっすぐな壁があるぞと思う
こういう状況です
でまっすぐなために触れながら
ます日に見える壁に触れながら実際には曲がった壁の周りをぐるぐる回っている
ですがこの人はまっすぐな壁を見て触ったらそこにあるから絶対まっすぐな壁だと信じ
ていて歩くと真っ直ぐ歩いてるのに感じてしまうということがわかります
で実はこれ直径6メートルのところをぐるぐるしてるだけなんですがこの人は無限に
真っ直ぐ歩いというような感覚を得ることができるわけです
我々が現実を感じる時に空間ってのがどういうふうに構成されているかというと実際に
体を使って歩いた感覚よりも
目で見て信じているとか触って信じているということがすごく強いので紅葉とが起こる
のだということがわかってきました
もう一つ例を挙げてみましょうこれは味を変える装置です
といっても食べ物は変わらないですねどういう装置かというとこのゴーグルを通して
みると普通のクッキーがですね
いきなりチョコレートのクッキーに香り見た目が変わるだけじゃなくてちょっとこれを
注い装置になってますが香りを出す装置が付いています
でチョコレートの見た目でチョコレートの香りを感じながら食べるとこの人は味が
チョコレートに感じてしまうわけです
だいたい8割とか8割5分ぐらいの人がそういう風に感じてしまいます
もちろん匂いと見た目の組み合わせは好きに変えられるので全く同じものを食べている
のに急にアーモンドクッキーになったり
ストロベリー軍気になったりそういうことができますそうすると例えば
病院食が美味しくなったりそういうことが塩分を抑えて治療家が強いとかそういうこと
をできるようになりますよねでこういうふうに
実は味っていうのは舌で感じているものだけではなくて鼻や目で感じている
もちろん盛り付けみたいなもうすぐ料理に大事ですけれどそういうところを考えてみる
と味を簡単に出すことができるということがわかってきます
こういうことができるのはなぜかというとぼ鑑定教科書レベルではセパレートして独立
したものだと習っていると思うんですが実際には感覚のは垣根を越えてお互いに影響し
あっているからなんですね
最近の脳科学とか人近くの研究のおかげでこういう影響が結構強いんだということが
わかってきました
こういう感覚の垣根を越えてお互いに影響しあってる影響をクロスモーダル近くといい
ますと
特によく起こる組み合わせ同士の間隔っていうのはすごく結びつきが深くなっていくな
のでまぁ見た目がチョコレートで香りがチョコレートだよねってなったらもう動画そこ
で複雑な処理をするよりももう味がチョコレートに来るに決まってるよね想像してそれ
で補ってしまうということが起こります
なのでこういう現象を使ってあげるとですね出すのが難しい感覚でも意外と簡単になっ
2人するっていうことがわかってきますなので我々の感覚って結構あやふやなんです
けれどそこを突いてあげると vr でいろいろなことができるというわけです
もう一個例を紹介してみましょうこれはですね拡張満腹感と呼んでるんですけれども
良いものかっていうと
ものを食べようとすると食べ物が大きく見えます
大きく見える状態を食べるとお腹いっぱいにすぐなる
すごい安直な研究ですよねこれがですね実際にどれぐらい聞くか
学生さんにおやつ食べ放題の実験があるんだけどくるって言ったらみんな喜んで着て
くれるんですね
そんな夢みたいな実験あるんですかまぁ実際にはですね
3日たできるだけコンディションを整えてもらって
同じような状態で食べてもらうんですけれどこの時に例えばこの子は小さいと13前
普通の時11枚で大きいともう7枚でお腹いっぱいになっちゃうということが分かり
ました
なのでこの人子は結構引きやすい子だったんですけれど
いっぱい
3被験者をとってみるとアベレージでプラスマイナス10%ぐらい食べる量変えること
ができます
で被験者の人にどれくらい食べる量を変えましたかって聞くと
や変えてないですよだって実験では同じだけ同じ
満足感が得られるまで同じくらい満腹になるまで食べてくださいと実地されてるじゃ
ないですか
言ってるわけで本人は無意識に食べる量を書いているわけです
なのである意味ではこれも無意識にダイエットする方法わけですね
でなぜこういうことが起こるかというと我々はお腹にバネばかりがついてわけじゃない
ので何グラム食べましたとか分からないで
その手堅いを見た目から得ているわけですなので見た目を変えるだけで我々がどれ
くらいお腹いっぱいになるとかどれくらい食べるっていう感覚とか行動が変わって
しまうというわけですね
なのでこういう感覚の影響を使ってあげると我々は実際に振る舞いを変えて食生活を
改めることができるようなんかもしれない
もうちょっと考えてみるとそういう感覚の影響っていうのがだんだん自分にも返って
くるということがわかってきます
でたとえばさっきの混ぜの話というのは自分の外にあるものを
見え方を変えていましたじゃあ次は自分の見え方を変えたらどうなるんでしょ
でそういう言及をちょっとやってみた例がこの扇情的な屈むという京急です
どういう研究かというと
鏡のように見えるんですけれど実際にはそこに映し出されているのは自分の今の顔と
ちょっと違う顔映ってるんです
少しだけ口角が上がって笑顔になっていたり少しだけ眉が下がって悲しい顔に見える
その時にどうなるかというと
鏡に映った顔に引きずられて感情が変わっていくんです
カメラから自分が笑っているとそれにつられて自分もどんどん楽しくなっていく
逆にちょっと悲しい顔見てるとちょっと悲しい気分になったりする
ってこういうふうにですね実は自分がどう見えているかということを利用してあげると
自分の感情をコントロールすることができる
もちろん使い方を誤ると怖いですけれどもしかするとうまく自分の感情と付き合って
いくことができるようになるかもしれない
例えばちょっと落ち込んだときに明るい気分になってあげるようなことにためにこう
いうものが使えると思っています
でなぜこの文学でこれを紹介したかというと実はこれをビデオチャットで使うという
ことを考えてみました皆さんもしかしたら
遠隔地の人とお仕事をされる時にビデオチャットみたいなものを使うことがあるかも
しれません
でだいたいですねビデオチャットで話しても
なんかリアルだったほうが良かったなーってなるわけですけれどここではちょっと変な
ことをやります
お互い子2人でアイディアを出すブレインストーミングをやるんですが普通にアイデア
を出すと東大生を呼びつけて5分でいっぱいアイデア出してねって言うと堪えて8つ
ぐらいているんですね
それその後にですねお互いが笑顔に見えるようにさっきの技術を使ってあげます
そうするとそれだけで何と内でが出る数が12個なので1.5倍になったんです
つまりなんかポジティブな状況で人と接するだけで我々はクリエイティブになるわけ
ですね
勉強しなくてもいいぱわれわれのパワーが出せるということがわかってきましたなので
こういうふうにコミュニケーションの中で自分がどう見えるかとか相手からどう
受け取られているかと言う印象を変えてあげるっていうことを
vr の技術みたいなもの応用し
てあげることによってわれわれはもっと能力が引き出せる環境が作れるということを
確かめています
でちょっとこういう言及についてもう一個事例を紹介してみましょう
さっきのは自分の見た目を変えるってことである意味大変身を扱った研究ですが今度は
分身を扱った研究ですで例えば皆で話し合いをして
何か答えを出さないといけないシチュエーションというのがあります
たとえばここに書いてあるのは砂漠遭難課題と呼ばれているんですけど
砂漠で飛行機が落ちましたとあなたたち
てにいっぱい荷物があるんで1個しか持っていけません
ヘルメットぱサングラスカーマスクどれか一個選んでください
皆さんで話し合っていく
決めてください行った時に二人が最初に3+って言った後に
ヘルメットってなかなか切り出しにくいですよね
もしくは切り出した時に皆さんブラスって言ってるんだからちゃんとサングラスって
言えよみたいな高圧力がかかってしまうけどこういうの同調圧力と呼ばれて日本だと
結構強いと言う風に
れていますよね
でも
本当は冷静に議論をしてほしいヘルメットいいところがあるかもしれないのでちゃんと
それはの皆が納得した上で決めたい
なのでこういう同調圧力をなんとか低減できないかなと思いました
そこでさっきの影分身です
これは人数が2対1だからいけないんですよね
このひとりの人か二人になっちゃえばいいんです
ただ安直な方法ですけれどこういうのを作りますとこちらは議事堂城効果生成システム
な道た理由も動画で
このように発言等発言の愛が在るブローに従って発言を体を2つに分割します
それを2台のは未だに交互にしゃべらせることで一人の場所は2人とにてかけます
今することで議事堂恐慌下の先生を図ります
こういうふうにですね一人が喋ってる話を切れ目を自動的に検出して
画面の中では2体の天田に割り当ててあげるということをやりますそうするともう1体
意識して努力して何かするんじゃなくて
無意識に普通にディスカションしてつもりで2人の
体を使いこなせてディスカッションしていることになります
これをですね先ほどの
弱い意見の人に使ってもらうわけですそうするとどうなるかというと
このこちら側に見えているのが
弱い犬の人が見えている画面なんですけど自分と違う意見の人が2人いるなぁと思って
一生懸命説明するわけですね
多数派だった人たちなどを見えているかと言うと自分と同じ意見の人が一人て自分と
意見の違う人が2人いるように見えますこの状態でディスカッションをするとどうなる
かというとなんと大合意が形成
された後に皆が納得しているっていう度合いが高まるということが分かりますと
で人数の影響とかってすごい些細なことのように見えるんですがこういうふうに結構
冷静な議論を妨げたりするわけですねそういうような影響が一に考え方のクセが
いっぱいあるよっていうことを分かったらそれを打ち消す方向に働きかけたりそれを
もっとポジティブに使う方法に語りかけることができるでしょ
でこういうこと
を vr の力をもってすれば色々な事に使っていけるのではないかということを考え
ています
なので人をもっと加速するために人をもっと人に優しくするためにこういうことを使い
たいと思っています
ここで見てきたように vr っていうのは人の感覚とか人時のしくみってのを
普段と違う環境を与えることによって白日のもとに探し出してしまうわけですなので
冒頭で皆さん
vr ってなんか違う世界に行って楽しかったって言って帰ってくるだけのものだと
思ってる
じゃないでしょうかという話をしたんですが実はそうではない
vr の中で体験した事っていうのは我々の心を支えていて我々はそれを現実に持って
帰ってきているので
vr 体験したことは現実の世界を変えていっているわけですね
なので我々が食べたものからできているように我々は情報のとして頭の中で処理した
ものと思ってして我々の心を作り出しているので我々は実は vr で体験したことを
かなり現実に持ってきているわけです
ということは vr っていうのは現実を変えていると言えるわけですね
それで今日最後の質問にしたいと思います
皆さんどんなふうに今自分や現実を変えたいと思っているでしょうか
おそらくまあ皆さんいろいろなことをかを考えだと思います
身の回りの現実とか自分のことを変えたいなと思う瞬間が結構あるんじゃないかと思う
んですけれど
おそらく vr はそれを手助けできる未来がすぐにやってくると思いますでも
を
vr で自分を変えてしまうって結構怖い技術ですよね
じゃあ何に使ってよくて何使っちゃいけないのかということを研究者だけでは考える
ことができません
なので皆さんに vr の技術で何ができるのかっていうのを知ってもらってそこから
いろんな
日常に関係するところで想像してもらってこういう使い方は私は許せるけど恋使い方は
許せないなというのを想像していただく
それを我々にフィードバックしいただけるとわれわれがこういう言及はしていいとか
こういう研究をしてはいけない
のがだんだんわかってきます
薬は用法用量というのがありますよね
あれはやっぱり長い蓄積の下でここまでだったら使ったら体にいいケルトこれ以上使う
と体に悪くなるって言うが分かってきている
おそらく vr にも朗報とか容量っていうのが必要だと思っていますそういうものを
決めていくためにもやっぱり皆さんの意見っていうのが大事なのでぜひ皆さんも vr
と社会の良い関係をどうやったら
作れるかっていうところをちょっとちょっと3時から体験から出発して一緒に考えて
いただけると今日は嬉しいですありがとうございました
[拍手]